we have a voicemail number that number
is
2192 david p uh here is the eggman
weighing in on the plan for some sports
stadiums
to have vaccinated and unvaccinated
sections take a listen
hi dave i hear that in the opening of
large uh sporting
arenas and stuff we're going to try to
be inclusive to people that are
unvaccinated and they're going to make
vaccinated people sit in one area
and unvaccinated people sit in another
area
i feel that is a complete recipe for
disaster
and it reminds me of when i was in italy
and i was seeing a soccer game it was
uh verona versus chievo verona right two
super enemy opposing teams and they seat
you
by which team that you root for so they
seek to
each side and separate sides of the
arena separated by a big
fence people were throwing cups of urine
weapons any bot anything you could think
that were on fire
there was anything you could name was
landing over and on my head from the
opposing team and i'm just imagining
the unvaccinated and vaccinated people
just fighting with each other
inside a sporting arena when one of
their teams lost
am i imagining things or could this
really happen shalom brother
yes of course shalom to the eggman yeah
i've experienced similar things you know
soccer games in argentina it's sort of a
similar situation
yeah i don't love it i would rather see
the stadiums take a more
definitive approach and say we want to
get back to full capacity and the way to
do it is
we're only going to allow vaccinated
people in because what some stadiums are
doing is
if you're vaccinated there will be one
section with full capacity every seat
can be full
in another section the unvaccinated
section they will only have every third
seat occupied
um one one for one person for every
three seats
and there's a bunch of different reasons
i don't like it what the eggman is
talking about is certainly a factor
but just just take a stand if you
believe clearly you believe vaccination
is safer because you allow people to sit
together
you don't on the unvaccinated side just
say for not only for safety but also as
a business decision
we want to fill every seat and the way
to do it safely is with everybody
being vaccinated let's see if every
teams make that decision if any teams
make that decision we have a great bonus
show for you today
the alleged capital rioters are still
being arrested to this day they're still
finding more and more of them
a california bar owner has been busted
for making
phony vaccination cards and a federal
judge has overturned
the national eviction ban
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
don't miss it get instant access and i
really do mean instant the speed of
light
by signing up at joinpackman.com i'll
see you then